genius brain listeners this podcast is
brought to you by
nordvpn if you're out there snoop snoop
snooping around on the interwebs why are
you doing it without a VPN specifically
nordvpn I don't go on Netflix I don't go
on a website without turning on a VPN
because I need to keep my information
safe oh yes for all of our listeners out
there hop on to nordvpn it's an
exclusive deal that I have for you grab
the nordvpn deal go to Nord vpn.com
geniusbrain and get extra subscription
time try it risk-free now with a 30-day
money back guarantee thanks to nordvpn
for sponsoring our show genius brain
listeners this podcast is brought to you
by fume we are talking about our sponsor
fume which is helping you break your bad
habits in a good way see with fume they
look at the problem in a different way
not everything in a bad habit is wrong
so instead of drastic and uncomfortable
change why not just remove the bad from
your habit fum has served over 150,000
customers and has thousands of success
stories and there's no reason that you
that we can't be you join fume in
accelerating Humanity's breakup from
destructive Habits by picking up the
journey pack today head to trif nume.com
and use code genius to save 10% off when
you get the journey pack today that's TR
f.com and use code genius to save an
additional 10% off your order today this
podcast is brought to you by mood what
is mood you ask well
my friends M Compadres mood is known for
their federally legal THC but now
they're adding their most potent product
yet to the lineup introducing hemp based
thca flower the future of legal THC try
it along with all of moods other amazing
offerings like Delta 8 flower gummies
Vape cartridges and more the experts at
mood have tested and tailored different
strains for specific moves from euphoric
to energize creative to chill and plenty
of versatile products that go with what
ever mood you're going for try mood's
new thca flow today and get 20% off your
first order and free gummies go to Hello
mood.com and use promo code genius
that's hello
o.com promo code genius for 20% off your
order and free gummies views and I was
bashing this guy based on what I thought
was true yeah sure you know what I'm
saying so I still do have to apologize
for it it doesn't [__] matter whether
I was tricked or not this tells a
completely different story in five 4 3 2
1 what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of The Genius brain podcast in
the new beautiful Studio we have Pete on
the mic over there what's up everyone
Pete with the Long Dong always going to
be that by the
way I wish I had a reputation like that
and then we got Ry with the stubby make
one for me hey hey we got stubby dick
Ryan dude it looks like a laser
battery I want one like
Pete fine dude we got the Filipino
F laser pointer
battery [__] is [__] this small
dude erect damn it
yeah dog so we were just talking about
this earlier where I had this weird
obsession with watching like Bollywood
films you sure you want to use that as a
segue later yes I do
100% all right so Bo if you guys have
never watched Bollywood films they are
so and even Series so Netflix had this
point where they were just acquiring all
this like Indian film and uh Cinema TV
shows long series short form whatever
the [__] that it was and there was this
I don't remember the actual name but I
wish somebody could tell me but it was I
don't even know what the [__] it was
about but I would be crying laughing
every [__] night because of how
ridiculous it is like when when some of
these series
would make the main character a
superhero they would do it to the 10th
degree yeah right so for example like if
we have like an American show and this
person is a secret agent they're very
good at shooting killing and attacking
people well in the Indian Bollywood
version of that he's catching a rocket
launcher with his bare heads right
flipping it up into the sky shooting a
satellite down grabbing debris and then
stabbing in somebody's eye right that's
their version of everything and you
would see these like on Tik Tok the best
dude and you would think that they're
only picking out like one or two shows
not true a lot of them are like that
there was this one episode I posted it
on a story years ago where I was crying
laughing because there was this whole
thing where they were doing like a
spiritual battle in this spiritual World
which I don't even know how they got
there and so this guy is fighting this
person the whole time and out of nowhere
the person that he's fighting in the
spiritual realm turns into into an eagle
don't know how oh good there was no
premise for him turning into an eagle
but he turns into an eagle right and Out
of Nowhere by the way they were fighting
for like 20 minutes he turns into a
[__] Eagle on the 20th minute it's
like Eagle time and then he turns into
an eagle out of nowhere yeah the guy
that he's fighting somehow pulls a gun
from his back and shoots him from the
sky that's the rebuttal for shape
shifting yeah but 20 minutes you had a
gun on you d That's genius genius then
out of nowhere he has a handgun and he
shoots the eagle from the sky
I cried laughing so [__] hard on in
this same show there is a scene this is
the ghettoest thing I've ever seen so
there's a dog chase this dog is chasing
this person and they're trying to get
this shot of the dog jumping over like a
fence or some type of object and they
have to get the undershot right but this
dog isn't a trained dog so do you know
what that cut was the dog jumps and then
you see the person's hand and he's
throwing the dog the dog launch we see
the launch of the guy still his hands in
frame of him throwing the dog and the
dog's body starts turning
sideways cuz it wasn't on purpose and it
made the Final Cut I'm not even [__]
lying I cried laughing till like my
belly hurt watching this show is this an
old old show no it was this came out I
think during pandemic so this was like
laws are that
liberal [__] J [__] and he
just throws this dog dog it cracked me
the [__] up man just tossed it I I can't
believe how it's like not supposed to be
funny but it's inadvertently the
funniest thing like did you see that
clip of that girl who was uh it it's
this very famous thing that you saw like
on Tik Tok on Instagram where she ends
up killing herself by choking herself
out on yeah on the little curtain the
little drape but she like spun into it
after like a
oh and then they're all just watching it
happen they're just like yeah just
[__] shock this [__] dog that's an
example and look if there's anybody out
there who is Indian who's like that's
not all of our shows of course maybe but
is that like to to an Indian person in
India is that meant to be like hey in
the comments below I need to understand
this like where's the irony level like
where's the satire at yeah cuz like are
people in India watching that and going
this is the best piece of Cinema I've
ever seen this is crazy how did she die
why did she die the Apex of this is just
fantastic I don't know I don't know if
that's what people are seeing or are
people in India watching this going what
the [__] is going on this is so weird
because if we're not if we're not a part
of the joke I don't know what's going on
yeah there's I a big part of me is like
there's no way that that is real one
thing I did learn is that sometimes when
you're watching Indian movies and the
character morphs into a thing or does
something crazy there's like a
historical story behind that and it's
like a representation of that yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah but like what's the
curtain thing I I don't understand that
curtain thing at all and like the
biggest thing that I've been doing now
is watching a lot of Indian Street food
and I've talked about this too where I
watch the Indian Street Food where it's
dope as [__] delicious as hell and then
cut to another video of a guy making
[__] Roy in his armpits yeah and he's
like holding [__] with his feet and he's
like
yeah like put something in his mouth and
go on the on the stove yeah it's crazy
I'm watching these videos and I'm like
clearly this is not normal because I'm
watching the other videos where it's
perfectly fine yeah they have gloves
things are clean [__] looks delicious
fire as [__] cut to a dude he's an
amputee with a piece of dough sticking
in his ARP and doing this Shing it how
but it's like would you would you know
the difference though like if you didn't
see the making of and you just ate it
would you would you be like this tastes
like a dude's armpit just a curly piece
of hair my teeth what is I mean I mean
being Filipino I can't really talk I
can't really say nothing you're like
what's wrong with this video I don't
understand what people why is that funny
David just get mad the there was this
other guy where I watched this video of
him breaking up an ice block which I
thought that he was going to just chill
some other stuff in it he smashed it on
the floor he picks up the ice and he
puts it in a drink what the [__] on the
floor on the floor oh my God hold on is
this a is this a prank is this like a
prank and now the guy just drank it he's
like yes as there's like 16 flies around
it's good it's good right like those uh
yeah when they open the bread thing and
there just and look the end product
looks great but how funny of these guys
were just putting it on for the video
they're like we don't really cook like
that you're [__]
idiots you're they're just like Elite
content creators I know we're all we're
the idiots it's a green screen yeah
they're not even in it's Hassan minhaj
pulls off his face speaking of great
segue
huh so listen even better even better
yeah so Hass minha I did a video and
listen I was pretty riled up about this
right yeah so if you guys go back to a
few videos it's with me Pat and Jason
and we're talking about how he was there
was a person in New York that did a a
piece uh on Hassan right and her name is
if I look it up right now her name is
Claire Malone and Claire Malone is a
journalist for the New Yorker right and
she wanted to fact check all the stuff
that he was saying um specifically in
his standup comedy specials or whatever
and Hassan kind of stayed silent so he
kind of got dragged through the mud yeah
um and even when I posted my video about
it where we were discussing it with me
and Jason chenny and Pat it was a bit
after all the stuff happened it was like
five or six days cuz usually when this
stuff comes out there's more information
that we have to digest before we get and
we State our opinion now everything is
alleged at this point so he didn't say
anything and so today he actually
released a video yeah refuting
everything that this reporter said with
receipts with receipts right so for
me to a certain extent I would say 80%
Hassan minhaj I apologize
cuz I I was really really severe uh
about the things that I said uh based on
what she wrote about you and I took it
as truth without waiting for his
response still don't think you're
funny I have to I have to stick with
that because that doesn't change but
once again comedy is very subjective
there's plenty of people who think he's
funny which is why he's successful for
me you do TED Talks so I do have to
apologize because we have to talk about
the [__] yeah that she conveniently left
out in their interview Y and Hassan did
I don't know if it was her recording
recorded messages or whatever whatnot or
recording of their interview recorded or
she did but it was recorded audio and he
has it and it tells a very very
different story all the context in there
it's so different it's very [__]
different it makes it really look like a
straight up HIIT piece mhm and I wonder
why when this came out what was her
objective right because the whole story
is not as exciting as what she told yeah
right so if you guys don't know about
this or you haven't listened to our
previous podcast I'm not going to take
down the podcast because it's what I
thought at the time and I'm just going
to rectify what I did in this podcast
right so the original thing was that his
um prom date her name her real name
isn't Bethany yeah but um basically he
told the story that the reason that he
came up to the door asking or whatever
whatnot her parents said I don't want
you dating a brown guy or whatever he
made it sound like it was like at the
doorstep and that it was like a very
cinematic thing yeah and then what it
kind of turned out to be was that she
apparently rejected him because she
already had a date uh and so it kind of
makes it look like he's race baiting
right but the full scope of the story
from what he told in the video that he
released today which we're actually just
going to watch right now if you guys are
going to go on Hassan minhaj's page he
does his whole explanation and we're
going to start with the Bethany story
here at 3 minutes and 30 seconds so in
homecoming King I told a story about how
I was supposed to go to prom with a
white girl named Bethany Reed her real
name is not Bethany I changed it to
protect her
anonymity I say that I show up at
Bethany's house on prom night but at the
doorstep her mom tells me they don't
want her to go to prom with me because
they'll be taking a lot of pictures and
they don't want their family back home
to see her with a brown boy Bethany's
mom did really say that it was just a
few days before prom and I created the
doorstep scene to drop the audio audence
into the feeling of that moment which I
told the reporter is the doorstep moment
true like did that happen no no it
happened before like but the emotional
truth Remains the Same her mom going hey
sweetie we like we take photos and we
don't want people to see we have family
back home did she sort of give that as
the reason of like my parents aren't
comfortable with going yeah and it was
it just destroyed me yeah sure that's
understandable the reporter said it's
understandable but none of what I
explicitly said makes in the article
this is what they wrote instead she told
me that she turned down minj who was
then a close friend in person days
before the dance minhaj acknowledged
that this was correct but he said that
the two of them had long carried
different understandings of her
rejection this whole paragraph makes it
sound like I got friends owned by
Bethany and then I turned into an angry
insult and then faked racism to get back
at her and I think this sentence is the
reason why people believe that he said
that the two of them had long carried
different understandings of her
rejection ction this sentence is
incredibly misleading and implies the
exact opposite of what I meant let me
explain okay over a decade after prom in
August of 2014 Bethany and I met at a
restaurant called Sarah bets in New York
and we cleared the air on what her mom
said to me at prom now I talk about this
in homecoming King and I also told the
New Yorker about this Meetup she had an
understanding that we were like totally
cool and like I had been carrying
something completely different and I
just told her what it meant like like do
you understand what it's like being like
a skinny Muslim da Brown kid in Davis
California and you know we're always
told to put our head down and just take
it and I did and I carried this water
for like years and years when the
article says we had different
understandings what I clearly meant was
that Bethany never knew how much her
family being racist had affected me
that's why we had different
understandings not because Bethany
denied this happened see that's a very
very different story yeah super
different from what we from kind of what
I also portrayed too because he's right
when I read this whole article that's
exactly how I interpret it not this
version of it yeah so for her as a
journalist her Integrity is absolute
[__] trash right and it really did
make him seem like he was this weird
little incel yeah I think for me too
when I read that originally I I could
imagine that being true because there's
a lot of guys that do do that that will
put the blame on like oh it's because
I'm Chinese it's cuz I'm Asian it's cuz
I'm whatever and they just totally glaze
over the fact that something's wrong
with them as a person so they'll just
like race bait that whole situation yeah
and I think for him I don't know how old
he is I think he's around our age too uh
there were like certain guys that kind
of did that they always blamed
everything else instead of them like you
being the awkward guy the obnoxious dude
you're super loud and annoying and then
when you look at a girl and they don't
like you they go oh it's because I'm
Asian or it's because I'm this and that
it's like no you're actually just
unattractive as a person yeah you know
exactly and so that's kind of what I got
out of that from the way that she wrote
it but in truth her parents actually
actually did say that [__] did say that
[__] the timing was a little off so he
kind of made
that maybe the one thing I also don't
understand for him too is he's like I
made the artistic choice to say it at
the doorstep right I was like dog it
would have been the same either way do
you think that's doing too much to kind
of try to condense it so the timeline's
like quicker maybe I you know but that's
not to his fault too that's not even a
problem right I think that what we're
finding here too and we'll talk about
this in depth later on as we watch some
more footage is that he kind of walks
the line of he keeps calling himself a
comic right and I don't think a lot of
people consider himself a comic they
consider him a political commentator I
that honestly that's what I thought he
was exactly and I mention not like to
insult him but I just always saw him on
Daily Show related stuff m and so for me
too I mentioned in the podcast not even
as a joke that when I was first
introduced to him it was I saw this
video of him because people were talking
about this video and I saw it it was
like H I don't want to watch a TED talk
so I turned it off and then somebody's
like oh have you heard of Hassan minhaj
I was like yeah I saw his Ted Talk and
they're like well he put out a standup
special on Netflix turn it on it was the
same video I was like oh this is a a
stand-up comedy special and that's what
I kind of knew a as I didn't know that
that was a stand-up special I you know
what I mean it's the same video it was
the same [__] video so for me I never
knew that he was a comic and I actually
found out on the podcast that he was he
was a writer for The Daily Show um and
so for him he kind of walks this line of
you say you're you're a comic which you
are right but I don't think a lot of
people view him as a comic and it's
because of the way that he portrays his
information when he told the story on
his
special it wasn't for a lap
it was to get people to understand what
it was like being a skinny brown Desi
boy right that grew up in Davis
California there was no real punchline I
didn't think there was either MH there
were some parts where there was like one
thing that was like a haha moment but
for the most of it is just very like it
just felt like he was just telling a
story yeah and that's the part where I
kind of disagree with him here right so
when he is fabricating some of these
things right when we put it in the in
the context of Comedy people fabricate
things for a bigger punchline joke and
we we buy into the Ridiculousness of
this oh okay I see what you're saying
yeah yeah but for him he said that he
did this to to make sure people feel
what he felt but what you felt wasn't
comedy there was no joke at the end of
this right cuz that's how he draws the
line cuz he said in political you have
to start with facts and then he said in
comedic storytelling you start with the
emotion and facts are second
but because it's talking that's so
racially that's noer comedic
storytelling it is political exactly and
this is where it kind of [__] up right
you hit the nail on the head with that
that's exactly what it is yeah cuz now
it's muddy MH and now we don't know what
the purpose of this it's like well now
the purpose seems like I want you guys
to understand how shitty it is to be an
indian-american yeah because it's
driving a sentiment mhm so where's the
joke so you can't really blame the
audience for not understanding what's
going on here yeah that's true yeah
right he kind of set the premise up so
for him as somebody who is a political
politically charged comic you know when
you start going into that realm how do
we know what you're saying is real or
not and then how are we supposed to
digest this information especially when
there's no punchline right yeah right
because when I see political humor I can
tell when these guys are being funny and
I could tell when they're talking about
real serious situations right so in this
case I didn't I still don't understand
cuz I did watch his special and I don't
see the punchline so and that's not to
say that he's not allowed to do this as
a writer or somebody who's a performer
but this is kind of where he gets [__]
a little bit right you know what I'm
saying yeah that's why people are going
to look into your [__] the same way like
if Dave Chappelle when he was talking
about his trans friend like if parts of
that weren't true of course people are
going to dig it out you know yeah and
like imagine to let's say in this story
he's like Dave Chappelle says well yes I
did have a trans friend I did have all
this other stuff but in the part of the
story where this where the transfer died
it actually didn't happen but the point
of this is that I want you guys to know
that it could
happen it's ter still terrible you know
what I mean it's still bad because like
it's still representative of all the
trans deaths that he's trying to allude
to exactly so it's like there was no
joke to this you're trying to teach
somebody a lesson off a hypothetical of
things that actually do happen to yeah
you're trying to influence an opinion
based on your story 100% so I think this
is where he kind of messed up right
genius bra listeners this podcast is
brought to you by
nordvpn if you're out there snoop snoop
snooping around on the interwebs why are
you doing it without a VPN specifically
nordvpn I don't go on Netflix I don't go
on a website without turning on a VPN
because I need to keep my information
safe for the longest time I just never
used a VPN and I don't know why like
information out there uh in the interweb
specifically your information needs to
be hidden and I just don't like people
knowing what's going on in my life in
general so why would I like that online
so ever since I've used nordvpn I kind
of you know web browse and serve very
safely and it kind of gives me that
peace of mind so for all of our
listeners out there hop on to nordvpn
it's an exclusive deal that I have for
you grab the nordvpn deal go to
nordvpn.com geniusbrain and get extra
subscription time try it risk-free now
with a 30-day money back guarantee
thanks to nordvpn for sponsoring our
show this podcast is brought to you by
fume cold turkey may be great on
sandwiches but there's a better way to
break your bad habits we're not talking
about some weird mind Voodoo we're
talking about fume my friends and they
look at the problem in a different way
not everything in a bad habit is wrong
so instead of a drastic uncomfortable
change why not just remove the add from
The Habit fume uses flavored air fume is
completely natural and most importantly
for me fume uses delicious flavor so you
get it instead of bad fume is good it's
a habit you're free to enjoy and makes
replacing your bad habit easy listen for
me I like the taste and for I fidget a
lot so fume is pretty dope because the
weight of it is cool it has like this
nice wood on it um and it gives my
fingers something to do so it helps with
like de-stressing and anxiety so stop
shopping is something we all put off
because it's hard but switching to fume
is easy enjoyable and even fun fume has
served over 150,000 customers and has
thousands of success stories and there's
no reason that can't be you join fume in
accelerating Humanity's breakup from
destructive Habits by picking up the
journey pack today head to tume.in use
code genius to save 10% off when you get
the journey pack today that's Tri f.com
and use code genius to save an
additional 10% off your order today
quick ad break my genius brain listeners
this podcast is brought to you by mood
if you're asking me how I sleep so well
at night and relax before I go to bed
I've been doing it with mood's thca
flower products baby let's go mood is
known for their federal legal THC but
now they're adding their most potent
product yet to the lineup introducing
hemp based thca flower the future of
legal THC try it along with all of
mood's other amazing offerings like
Delta 8 flower gummies Vape cartridges
and more and for a limited time mood is
giving your listeners our our listeners
free Delta 9 gummies and 20% off our our
or your first order just visit hood.com
and use our code genius mood's latest
and most potent breakthrough in the
world of legal cannabis is thca flow
since thca converts into THC when you
heat it you get access to the classic
marijuana High mood puts an end to
guessing games with federally legal
forms of THC extracted from hemp plant
try mood's new thca flow today and for
20% off your first order and free
gummies go to hood.com and use promo
code genius that's hello
m.com promo code genius for 20% off your
first order and free gummies so this is
the part where he talks about the
implied quote unquote carelessness of it
all right where he kind of got her doxed
and everything else and so he has
receipts where he can address that yeah
with my carelessness so I want to show
you evidence that shows that that isn't
true back in November of 2015 when
homecoming King was running off Broadway
Bethany came to the show and this is how
the New Yorker reported it the woman
said that minj had invited her and her
husband to an off Bradway performance
she had initially interpreted the
invitation as an attempt to rekindle an
old friendship but she now believes the
move was meant to humiliate her I
promise it was never my intention dude
to humiliate Bethany at the show that
one's way off yeah is false I looked
back at our emails and I found out that
I didn't invite Bethany to that show she
emailed me out of the blue and told me
that she was coming because her friend
saw the show
said they after the Bethy also texted me
that it was awesome and we kept in touch
for years I included her in the journey
with full transparency I put her in
touch with fact Checkers from This
American Life I invited her to the
Netflix premere party I even emailed her
to take down a tweet that might reveal
her identity Bethany then responded with
a really nice email that ended with her
saying PS thanks for the heads up on the
tweet I deleted the other ones but this
one escaped me it's shockingly hard to
resurface old social media apparently
how different
me and my family I don't think I've ever
formally thanked you for that and I do
sincerely appreciate it's like so
severely oppos so different photos of
Bethany or her family those are actors
and their faces are blurred maintaining
Beth's an on so different even his Wiki
says that that's a real photo I would
never want her to get doxed or harassed
and if there were any negative
consequences that came your way Bethany
I am sorry about that I am not perfect
but I promise I am not needlessly cruel
even though that's what the New Yorker
wants you to believe despite the
evidence I was an open book I sat down
in good faith they had my testimony in
four years of Correspondence backed up
with receipts all on the record that
showed my race was a factor in my prom
rejection I wasn't careless with
Bethany's privacy and she thanked me for
keeping her family's identity safe so
how could the New Yorker imply the oppos
they had to know what they were looking
for when they were asking here's the
bigger question
why did the New Yorker fact check my
standup special but not properly fact
check their own article if you're still
here I have have you heard the theory
about I don't know if it's like that
crazy of a theory about how like after
he had done that content that was kind
of
scrutinizing uh the Saudis MH shit's
been kind of like this for him like kind
of on a yeah it's like people are trying
to take him down now maybe dude I mean
he's kind of when you start going into
this political realm it gets a really
tricky and very [__] dangerous right
so if that's the case I 100% believe it
cuz he said I think he said something
that criticized uh the the Crown Prince
yeah as a joke or like for real um I
don't know I don't know if it but it was
like criticizing something about how
they do [__] and it was like he said
since then he's been receiving that's
when the letter came in with the [__] in
it like that's when people have been
just [__] with him that's [__]
crazy man and like journalistic
Integrity is such [__] trash right
and once again I will say this again I
do have to apologize because even if I
was tricked or fooled or whatever
whatnot I have a platform that video got
whatever 25k 30k views and I was bashing
this guy based on what I thought was
truth yeah sure you know what I'm saying
so I still do have to apologize for it
it doesn't [__] matter whether I was
tricked or not this tells a completely
different story yeah and the idea like
they have look at he sent all this stuff
to her and she just took it and threw it
away four years years years of
Correspondence could you I can't even
wrap my head around that [__] and then
for her she just goes okay whatever the
funny thing is it's
like he is now he got he's being
scrutinized for embellishing [__] and
now she's being in trouble for ell she
[__] a weird what a weird place to be in
you know I mean it the irony of that
it's so [__] ironic and she's the one
that's supposed to be fact checking like
he's he's allowed some wiggle room but
they're not this is so dangerous too
because you know and I should know
better than this too because there have
been so many things said about me and my
friends everybody else that's just
blatantly not true and people kind of
run with this [__] narrative and I'm
kind of now in this group of people too
where I did the same to him so I
actually kind of feel bad yeah yeah I
feel bad too cuz it I totally bought it
as like oh another guy doing this [__]
you know you know and once again I I
forgot that I expect journalism to be
truthful yeah right and for some [__]
reason me being the idiot I just took
everything that she said for fact and
truth without waiting for his response
and trust me it wasn't because I needed
fresh content it was just fresh in my
[__] mind and I really wanted to talk
about this with two other people who
were Comics just to talk about his
Integrity right yeah and once again just
because I don't find him funny it
doesn't doesn't mean that he's not funny
to other people right I just do that
obviously as a joke cuz I like pissing
people off but um it's just that at the
time when I read this stuff it just to
me it was true because see she was the
fact Checker when you say fact Checker I
just immediately think oh this has to be
true because she did her job as a
journalist to tell us the truth about
this guy who's a habitual [__] liar
you know yeah made him look like a like
a crazy guy like a crazy person right um
and so number one biggest thing the
[__] photo wasn't even real yeah it's
not even it's just like a random ass
stock photo of actors two two actors
that were hired actors and it was
blurred out so he did the job of
protecting her identity twofold MH right
which is pretty [__] amazing yeah he
didn't have to do that but he actually
did which I thought was really great she
knew this and she still decided to put
this hit piece out and I wonder why who
the [__] what is her agenda what is the
point of this did does it have anything
to do with like him taking over The
Daily Show cuz I'm seeing that a lot oh
they like they don't want him to be
someone doesn't want him to take over
the Daily Show what who the [__]
cares who the [__] cares maybe Saudi
cares a little I know they're sitting
with their oil money like this mother of
[__] yes could be mother of [__]
facial hair [__]
[__] I I don't [__] know
that's my Saudi
impression no one knows what they really
sound like use his all of his our oil on
his hair I hate him son of a mother of
[__] I'm sorry Hassan once again Hassan
I
apologize I apologize
profusely for the fact that I actually
believed this white
demon and I should have treacherous
white demon I should have cided with my
side dude I'm sorry dude yeah but like
how would you know though that's the
crazy thing it's like the receipts that
he brought out tell such a 180 on all
the info that was put it's like how
would you even be able to tell how
[__] different dude it's not even
like oh some of the [__] she said was
true it's literally zero and she was the
fact Checker yeah and the stuff that he
did change is like negligible details
that kind of just make for a better
storytelling experience but the meat is
still true 100% man and that that was
the thing that he was getting
scrutinized for the most it's like what
is Define line between Comics
embellishing a story and just outright
lying right and then can they actually
do it yeah and so the stance that I took
was if it's for comedy and the joke and
the premise is that everybody is in on
the joke then it's fine but when you
start doing these points of morality and
you paint this picture of this terrible
world and you get people to believe in
this [__] yeah then it becomes a [__]
problem cuz now you have this weird
political agenda or just like social
agenda and you're not making people
laugh you're making people believe that
this world is terrible yeah they're
walking out thinking that Earth is a
different planet 100% yeah and that was
my biggest contention with the things
that he was saying yeah it wasn't comedy
and I think a lot of the stuff he does
isn't comedy and I don't I don't think
he really understands that too people
don't really look at you and connect to
you because you're a comic they look for
the emotional story and they want to
feel that they are seen and they're
heard and that's the stuff that he puts
out right but if he's saying like oh I'm
just a comic this is comedy you you
don't do a good job at that then right
you know what I mean cuz I was watching
it like a TED talk like oh this me too
yeah yeah yeah this is a powerful Ted
talk but I'm trying to laugh so skip you
know move it on I don't care about your
[__] prom date and you going like
brown boy get off of my step I don't
care about this dude I'm I really don't
care for this you know what I mean I
wanted to laugh and you didn't do it so
I just kind of moved on a lot of other
people who saw that they they they
recommend it to me because they said
they CED died watching his stuff because
of how how they felt seen and heard but
they weren't like dying laughing over it
no none of the people who liked it that
I know liked it because of the comedy do
you think that still qualifies as comedy
in any way to be like even if you don't
laugh one one time I think that it's
it's a TED Talk I think it's a really
good Ted talk right I think it's a good
depiction of his story and whatever
agenda that he wants to go ahead and you
know put out to everybody but in terms
of comedy and like you know I I I think
a lot of IC say this they they don't
understand these new waves of comics
it's like why are you calling yourself a
comic you're not here to make people
laugh you're here to just tell these
personal trauma stories you know
cuz if I was still pursuing standup
comedy right I think for me as a comet
it would suck if the only thing that
people walked away was like dude I
related to your story I was like did you
laugh no I'm like okay then what am I
doing here yeah and I've seen this a lot
if you guys have been to comedy shows um
not all the time but I've been seeing
this trend in the last like six or seven
years of comics just using comedy as a
stage for your therapy right yeah yeah
yeah with no joke yeah it's like you
think it's going to flip at the end and
then they just go thank you exactly and
I'm they walk off stage and I'm like and
then people are clapping you're so brave
I don't give a [__] I'll be in the lobby
if you want to talk to me about my abuse
yeah where is the [__] joke I'm here
to laugh I'm not here to hear about why
you got touched in your butthole once
can you imagine 10:30 at Laugh Factory
that's the set you're watching you're
like oh [__] uh I'm drunk and I still
didn't laugh so I don't know what the
[__] is happening here dude maybe it's
just like so Advanced it's like you're
supposed to laugh making fun of this I
know and like AR spear said too it's
like if if you do a set that you feel is
so good and people aren't crouched over
belly laughing then are you really doing
your job as a comic you know that's true
and I agree when I go to when I see
standup comedy shows I'm not there to
critique people's comedy I'm not there
to take notes I just want to laugh with
everybody right and if I go into these
comedy shows and then people just make
complaints about you know toxic
femininity toxic masculinity no
punchline what am I listening to you
know what worse than that crowd work
that's all that oh my god dude dude
there's a big conversation too with
Comics saying
like some some Comics are looking so
forward to doing crowd work they don't
actually do a set yeah I you know I
started hearing that too yeah I've seen
it where look there's a there's a guy
that was famous on Tik Tok he's going
around doing a comedy tour and I've seen
him perform twice and his actual
material is not funny at all and the
whole time him he's just doing crowd
work saying absolutely nothing and then
he he's up there for like half an hour
I'm like what the [__] are you doing up
there and the crowd workor is the sorest
crowd work I've ever seen in my life and
a lot of people think now as people who
are com Like Comics are trying to do
their set they've worked on like there's
a beginning middle and end to this [__]
and then now people in the crowd are
thinking oh I want to be a part of this
Tik Tok video right so they keep
interrupting want to be in the moment
yeah what is this [__] it's like as an
audience member I'm like shut the [__]
up I want to hear the joke it's funny
cuz I always thought in my mind because
I'm not a comedian like that I always
envisioned crowd work so hard and then a
comedian was talking to me the other day
when we were at JK and he was like dude
Crow work's the easiest thing anything
you say will be funny
the it's the timing it's not it's not so
much what you're saying it's like if you
say it at the right timing everyone just
laughs cuz they're supposed to I was
like oh I didn't think of that like I
and usually to like really good Comics
goes they go into a crowd work and they
kind of go into a set after yeah right
there's like a segue to it there's a
Segway or they do another set on the fly
or it aids it aids the set and now I'm
just seeing guys just ramble to the
crowd for [__] 10 minutes it's all
crowd workout it's just all crowd work
and it's not even any jokes it's just
them people just giggling cuz they're
talking to a person in the crowd then
this would be your worst night if it was
just
Hassan it would be the [__] worst
dude anybody uh have any traumas uh who
else is a brown boy who hated their skin
huh I hated
it so we're going to talk about the the
let's we're going to go into the part of
the video where he talks about him being
slammed onto a car
right that my friends is
right damn almost almost almost
almost right here talk about which was
right where I was at before F of him he
slammed me against the hood of a cop car
the truep special but not properly fact
check their own article if you're still
here I have two more stories that I want
to address now in my second special the
king's Jester I tell a story about how I
met and was harassed by an FBI informant
named brother Eric I talk about how he
tried to entrap me at a gym and when I
made fun of him he slammed me against
the hood of a cop car the truth is I did
have altercations with undercover law
enforcement growing up and that
experience formed the basis of this
story but it didn't go down exactly like
this so I understand why people are
upset people face real danger at the
hands of the police and false stories
can undermine real stories and I am
sorry I added to that problem my
intention wasn't to take away from these
stories it was to Spotlight them through
my special that's why I used this story
to talk about hammed hay hammed and I
were part of the same NorCal Muslim
Community when he got entrapped it
rocked our community and he spent 14
years in prison we were the same age
same background and like him I also had
run-ins with undercover agents I was
even physically harassed by them while
playing basketball now you're probably
wondering why not just say that so this
is not an excuse it is an explanation of
my process when I am
storytelling Every Beat has to do
multiple things in a funny and impactful
way with the story I had a set of three
plot points the moment I realized
authority figures hate being made fun of
why I name my show Patriot Act and
Spotlight the story of hammed hayya the
problem is 99% of people watching
Netflix have no idea the FBI spoted on
Muslims at mosques or they don't even
believe it was real and I know this
because when I performed earlier
versions of the story in front of
audiences they had no idea what I was
talking about
FBI agents embedding in mosques and
entrapping young Muslims through
basketball or weightlifting or whatever
it sounds know but it was all over the
country that's that's all that guy took
my mosque in my hometown put a doily on
his head and call it a day and the
footage that I used in the special
proves that it was very real and very
stupid I wanted to recreate that feeling
that only Muslims felt for a broad
audience the feeling of paranoia this
one this one's a little bit iffy this
one is super [__] iffy dude because
it's like you said now that you said
like if it's not funny why not just tell
the truth story exactly it's not even a
joke exactly and this one I call
[__] yeah I I would have to agree
with you on that I call Big [__] and
it goes back to the conversation that we
had earlier once again he said that I
have a a task to do when I'm a
Storyteller is the emotional part and
the funny part sorry there was no joke
yeah and that's that's a big change
that's changing it to it happened to me
mhm versus it happens to us exactly
that's a big difference man it makes him
look like this martyr right and by the
way I once again I begrudgingly saw this
whole thing right I saw the whole
special so once again there are people
might say oh there was a few jokes here
and there but there was no real
punchline we didn't walk away laughing
we walked away feeling like dude this
poor Muslim kid got [__] bullied
because of the color of his skin and you
attribute it to his experiences you're
like oh man he went through that that's
crazy yeah so for him to go on here and
say like I'm not making excuse you are
making an excuse you are 100% are making
excuse you're we're not going through
your whole writing process and by the
way we shouldn't have to know your
writing process to laugh you [__]
idiot what are you talking about right I
apologize for the previous one this one
no sorry you are full of [__] on this
part we as an audience do not need to
know the comics writing process to lap I
don't need to know the writing process
of somebody's movie to enjoy the film
your job as a comic is simply to make us
laugh to bring us into this story and in
order for you to do that all you did was
make yourself look like a victim so I
don't agree with this one yeah this
one's little [__] this one's stretchy as
as far as you go he should have just
left this one as like you know what I
kind of fumbled this one a little bit
right I wanted to make the story more
bigger and better and it didn't have to
be and the real stories were there and I
could have just used it did and I also
don't buy the thing where he goes well I
told the story and people just didn't
believe it that actually helps I think
it does too I think it's great when
people have no idea what you're talking
about then you could really like get
creative MH and if his intention is to
educate people on the people who don't
know then what better way to show that
this actually happened you have a whole
[__] screen behind you you just did
it right now on the screen with all the
Articles and the funny that was
hilarious that was probably the funniest
thing out of this whole thing was him
showing the buff guy with the oily on
his [__] head Jesus Christ and he
like and he's going let's go let's go
we're going in alhamdulillah yeah and
that is really cool to learn like I
would like to go to a show and learn
that that's that's pretty awesome yeah
and you're and I'm pretty sure people in
the crowd too who go to your stand-up
comedy specials by the way husten
they're there for you so you're not
there to convince anybody of this right
right you know what I mean you're not
like believe me it happened exactly if
you put this out and I saw that I would
like oh [__] I didn't know that and it
would have made his story yeah that's
the reason people cared that he might
have made it up cuz they believed you
exactly so none of this actually makes
sense at all yeah this one's kind of a
right it's shaky and the funny thing was
that even when as I opened this up and I
read the comments everybody's talking
about only the first 12 minutes of the
video and they didn't watch the rest cuz
nobody's addressing this part they're
just going how could she do this blah
blah blah yeah yeah yeah cuz I get it
that's like that's the hot one that's
the hot one this one I really do
disagree with like you definitely put
that story and it made you look like the
victim whether that was your intention
or not you fumbled so bad on this one
yeah you didn't have to so there there
never was like a grab throw in the car
that never even happened never happened
see that's a big detail versus putting
the scene on a doorstep versus three
days prior like that's like exactly
that's embellishment this one's an
outright lie that makes people hate
other people and I don't agree with that
at all because where is the joke right
yeah right you know what I'm saying you
have to embellish on the parts that's
the comedy part you don't embellish on
the part where you look like the victim
yeah it's just an awareness campaign
that's I guess it was supposed to be
funny but yeah I I don't know I mean
like if you guys are watching up until
this point I wonder if you agree or
disagree yeah like if you guys agree or
disagree I would really like to know
because in my mind this part doesn't
make sense I 100% on am with him on the
first half oh yeah me too yeah there is
no excuse for that piece of [__]
whatever her name was [__] but I
think he's smart enough to do it in this
order because he knows that you're
already feeling like oh man I was wrong
and then he's like let me if you feel
like that check this out exactly you
know most people didn't even get to this
part they just listen to this first part
and by the way this first half the first
12 minutes is the part that he posted on
his social media and that's all people
are seeing that they haven't seen this
part I disagree with this 100 to be
honest the first time I saw this this
totally glazed right by me too see I was
like smart oh yeah it really did he's
because he starts talking about this
other dude who was in jail for 14 years
and that just like takes precedence over
everything you're like oh how horrible
you know like and you forget that like
he tried to like shoehorn himself into
this whole like narrative and you know
he did make a good point too he's like
you know people are asking him like you
know in terms of like the factchecking
thing and oh did you ask this informant
if it's okay to bring out this
information go nobody [__] asked me
if it was okay for him to spy on us I
agree with that I agree with that too so
he doesn't owe that piece of [__]
anything right but the whole thing where
he got slammed to a car like people
walked away listening to that thinking I
can't believe you got assaulted for just
being a brown person in America you know
and he yeah so you know it goes back to
me saying well um what if there was a
woman who told this story about her
being sexually assaulted and it never
happened and her excuse was I wanted to
bring people into the idea that people
get sexually assaulted even though it
wasn't me yeah I just don't like that
people hook those things together
they're like oh if you don't don't
believe me are you saying that women
aren't being assaulted every day it's
like dude I get what he's trying to do
with trying to tell you like oh this is
a thing that happened and nobody knew
and they should know but that doesn't
mean you get to like make up some bonus
you know storybook stuff about yourself
and so when he says stuff like emotional
truth this is where he gets caught up
yeah I could see I could see where he's
what he's thinking with that because you
can't do that on any other stuff like I
said I'll bring it up to the girls and I
know women who get [__] on would get
on if they did that in terms of stories
like that so he doesn't get an excuse
they be crucified for that 100% And I
think that's [__] unfair right if
you're going to crucify a girl for
making up stories like that then you
should crucify him for doing this for
something that's very serious as like
Prejudice and racism right I don't think
that's right no let's go to the next
part of the video my lovely genius farts
this podcast is sponsored by Harry no
matter why you shave harri's has you
covered for the best shave of your life
at a price you'll love from the
legendary high quality razors to skin
products like exfoliating face wash and
Hydrating Lotion Harry's gives you a
premium shave without the premium price
tech get better quality and a better
price than other razors when you get
haries delivered right to your door keep
your face baby smooth like I have for
years by using Harry's Razors before
they even sponsored this podcast uh I've
been using Harry's for a very long time
so this was a no-brainer because it's
just great I mean if I didn't like it I
wouldn't be using it I wouldn't have it
in my house in the first place right so
yes get on that haris because their
savings are super hard to beat and guess
what for the rest of your life you're
going to be having to get razors anyway
so you might as well get high quality at
a really really good price Harry's has
the highest customer satisfaction in the
Shaving industry and they're still
offering a no risk trial so don't like
your shave no worries it's on them so
get your best shave ever this summer
with Harry's razors and skincare
products get a $13 start ass for just $3
and at harry.com genius that's
harry's.com genius for a $3 Starter Set
genius brain listeners let's take a
break and talk about our sponsors over
at betterhelp I mean what needs to be
said about our longtime sponsors better
help I've said it before and I'll say it
again mental health is mental wealth and
I love it and I have been a huge
advocate of therapy because it's not
just what helped me throughout my early
years it helps me out now as an adult
and if y'all are open to speaking to a
licensed and professional therapist why
not try it with better help if you're
thinking of starting therapy give better
help but try is entirely online designed
to be convenient flexible to suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge therapy
gives you a place to get out all of
those negative thoughts and those
negative cycles that you're in and find
some mental and emotional piece it's
done that for me and I just can't
imagine a life without therapy
especially when when I need it and I
don't use therapy every day but when I
have it in my back pocket I always go to
better help and it's just been the best
so get a break from your thoughts with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com genius
toay to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com genius as a Muslim talk about how
I received a letter in the mail and when
I opened the letter white powder fell on
my daughter and we had to take her to
the hospital only to find out it was not
real Anthrax this as you know is not how
it went down and let me me just say I am
sorry for embellishing the story or if
anyone was worrying about me and my
family I
apologize but let me make something
clear a letter with white powder was
sent to my apartment in February of 2019
I opened it in the kitchen powder fell
on the table and my daughter was just a
few feet away it was powdered Donuts
realized it was not Anthrax and that
someone was [__] with me because
people had been [__] with me since
January 1st 2019 after this happened
Netflix Under Fire today after its
decision to pull an episode of a comedy
show that was critical of Crown Prince
Muhammad bin Salman the truth is when
this news broke my life got very scary
Saudi Bots were spamming my socials a
threatening letter was sent to Netflix I
was getting weird phone calls at night
then fake anthrax was sent to my house
and after that happened I asked Netflix
for our security guard to follow me
everywhere and people noticed friends
were texting me about seeing me rolling
everywhere through New York with
security and at one point my wife even
asked our security detail if he knew any
companies that sold those tiny GPS
trackers for strollers because we were
concerned that someone might try to
kidnap or hurt our daughter that is all
real the danger at that time was
palpable but beina and I decided to keep
the anthrax scare private because we
were worried that Netflix might shut
down my show which would have put my
entire staff out of work now you might
be wondering this is all terrifying so
why embellish why even say you took your
daughter to the hospital the night of
the anthrax scare Bea and I we got into
a huge argument and she kept asking
husten what if this powder fell on our
daughter so I created the hospital scene
to put the audience in that same shock
and fear that me and beina felt playing
out that night then I added the
investigator character because women in
my life were telling
that beina was coming off super Naggy in
old versions of the story so I gave some
of Bea's lines to other character so
that her perspective was represented in
a way that didn't reflect poorly on her
again I am sorry if I crossed a line
here but I told this story this way to
put the audience on the roller coaster
ride that we were both experiencing at
that
time now look I understand why people
were upset by all of this different
commun iians have different expectations
built into their
personas I thought I had two different
expectations built into my work my work
as a storytelling comedian and my work
as a political comedian where facts
always come first that is why the
factchecking on Patriot Act was
extremely rigorous the factchecking in
my congressional testimony deeply
rigorous I don't think there's any
comedian on Earth who has stood in front
of more data Vis than me but in my work
as a storytelling comedian I assume that
the lines between truth and fiction were
allowed to be a bit more blurry and I
totally get why a journalist would be
interested where that line
sits I just wish the reporter had been
more interested in their own premise
someone genuinely curious about truth
and standup wouldn't just fact check my
specials they would fact check a bunch
of specials they would establish a
control group a baseline to see how far
outside the bounds I was in relation to
others and they wouldn't just
cherry-pick a few stories they would
give their readers a sense of
proportionality what was true versus
what was false in my last special I talk
about almost getting sued by a hedge
fund 100% true getting ball surgery so
we could have kids 100% true Netflix
pulling my episode on Saudi and Saudi
100% true getting rejected from prom
because of my race
1,000% true D the reporter yeah that's a
lot dude genuinely curious about the
idea of Truth and standup they would
have had to report that the majority of
my stories are true but their article
LED with the opposite saying much of my
standup never happened to me that is
false nearly all of it happened to me
some of it didn't even the last line of
the article is stripped of the context
to leave you with the impression that
I'm some sort of unrepentant liar
he told me the emotional truth is first
the factual truth is secondary we tried
really hard to have them put in the full
quote with full context but they refused
so let me leave you with the full
context when people see a Hass Min
show there's two different expectations
there's the H Min has you see maybe here
at the comedy Celler where there is an
implicit agreement between the audience
like we're going down into a basement
like we're about to see a one-hour
comedy show that feels like there is an
emotional roller coaster ride sure then
there's husten minhaj the guy you've
seen on The Daily Show as a
correspondent or the guy from Patriot
Act on Netflix which is I am not the
primary character the news story is the
primary character with the latter the
truth comes first comedy sometimes come
second to make the infotainment the
sugar on the medicine in this the
emotional truth is first the factual
truth is secondary in political comedy
facts come
first in comedic
storytelling emotions come
first that is what I said and that is
what I
meant going forward will I be more
thoughtful about sticking to the facts
in my storytelling
absolutely I have no problem with honest
good faith critique because I am always
trying to improve as a performer
and as a
person look the guy in this article is a
proper [__]
psycho but I now hope you feel like the
real me is
not I'm just a guy with IBS and low
sperm
motility again there is much more
important
news this comedy dude talk
about that was pretty that was pretty
bad that's hard that was a little rough
guy you're not you're not helping
yourself right there but see by his own
laws he has to do that at the end or
else it's not comedy it's not ComEd so
that's this whole thing like this this
is we're essentially watching his
special yeah this is this is another
special this is the same feeling I had
from watching his special it was all
this and then one little sperm motility
IBS
IBS does it bother you at all that like
he showed so much proof and receipts for
everything but then when it came to the
anthrax letter he just said it happened
yeah he didn't have anything to show
like he's just the the proof is that
he's saying it happened it happened yeah
which I find that kind of weird it's a
little weird for me too cuz all of these
like factual stuff and this is the part
where he's like it happened yeah he's
like no that one for real believe hey
for real Z dude think you promise I
swear Cross My Heart Hope To
Die like there's really that that one I
think is so strange like that one I feel
like could be completely made up yeah
maybe that's for us to decide as as an
audience member and the thing that once
again you know he kind of addressed it
too he goes why did I decide to lie
about this and it was because I wanted
to make my wife look better she came off
Naggy yeah I don't really buy that
either I don't buy that you know what I
mean like you liked the emotional effect
that it has of your daughter having
Anthrax on her like like it's so major
yeah like you you literally used your
daughter as an emotional Pond for the
story when you didn't need it you know
what
and I'm pretty sure anybody who heard
the story it would have had the same
effect the original story is actually
better it's actually way better yeah you
know what I'm saying it's way [__]
better and who's going to sit there and
think that your wife is an [__] when
your job puts your daughter's line life
on the line yeah like we're all thinking
of Anthrax on a kid I'm not going to
stop and be like that wife is pretty
Naggy about that an I know uh you know H
son our kid could have what a [__] what
a [__] ax is deadly but so is
nagging the real lethal household a
nagging wife you're scared about Co
think about a nagging
life we got a [__] test for that get
the jab but don't nag all right hey babe
can you put this in your [__] nose I
want to see if you're a
[__] there's no vaccine for a [__]
wife I know dude like why would you
think that that would take precedence on
anyone's mind I don't know like I said
most people didn't watch up to this
point it just sounds like a writer's
room it sounds like literally like I
think she sounds Naggy all right I'm G
change that yeah it just sounds like a
writer's room dude and you know Andrew
Schultz kind of said this too where
maybe he kind of knew about this a
little bit he goes dude your regular
life is pretty crazy so why did you have
to do this and I think this is probably
what he was alluding to like you didn't
need any of that type of stuff why did
you do this but to his credit I do agree
I well I I do agree that he kind of got
scrutinized extra hard compared to
everybody else yeah yeah I think so too
but on the other flip side of this is
because you keep saying that political
comedy and regular comedy there's no
laugh everything seems hyper poitical
you know what I mean you proved it by
letting that IBS fly right by you you
decide to make that joke and then you're
the only one that laughed at it so you
know just Jesus where was hard to watch
that part where's your writer's friend
at that point he had such a yeah like
after saying it
right where the [__] are your friends
now how come they didn't take that joke
out he a let me just break the tension a
little bit Yeah but once again this is
the same feeling that I got from his
Netflix special right it was all this
seriousness and then he goes well you
guys know it's standup right no we don't
that's the problem we don't know it's
standup the only moment that I realized
he was stand up where you made the poop
joke oh my god dude yeah and so maybe
this is where he can probably figure
this stuff out he goes oh maybe I'm not
really a comic I'm actually somebody
who's more a political commentator who
can who have who has a few humorous
quips here and there and that's how most
people see him as and this is why he's
getting so much scrutiny so I don't
really think that in his case he's a bad
person right no he's any of that type of
stuff I think that he has a branding
issue in his own head I'm a comic I'm a
funny guy but if we if we as the
audience don't look at him or watch his
stuff for comedy and we only look at him
to feel seen or heard then are you
really a comic you might just be a
self-proclaimed comic at this point
you're a successful political
commentator that has a few jokes and
that's not a negative thing at all so do
you think that like like is Bill Maher
funny to you in the same way or uh
Trevor NOA or Bill Mah's funny to me
either like if Bill somebody said Bill
Mah is a stand-up comic which apparently
he is I only found that out because I
listened to a Joe Rogan podcast where he
had a set he was doing I was like wait
Jo Bill Mah does stand up so once again
Bill Mah falls into this category as
well right cuz if Bill Mah did this he
would get crucified too he's not exempt
from this as well if Bill M made of
Muslim victim
stories yeah I have to fact check that
bill come here Bill's like yeah you know
when I was uh when I was at a mosque and
I was
praying I was slammed onto a car and
that was
crazy oh oh oh my God I believe him I
believe him so much the emotional truth
is hurling me yeah so I didn't know I
didn't know that bill mtin didn't stand
up until I heard Rogan because his
original thing is standup yeah that's
like how he started and everything right
yeah I didn't [__] know that I
thought he was a political commentator
that made a few funny jokes even Trevor
Noah now right when he first started off
he was just a standup comic yeah and
when I watch him on his show I don't
look at him as a stand-up comic anymore
he's a political commentator and I I
think even for him as somebody when I
first saw his first special was really
funny because he has gone so much on the
political side yeah it his new standup
isn't as funny it's like kind of just
whatever yeah right that's my opinion
once again like don't don't take any of
this as truth this is just what I feel I
mean I think it's generally agreeable
that most political comedians in Mass
are less funnier than
comedians cuz they could make a joke
about anything because it's if it's not
your bag it's just you're not going to
laugh at anything no matter how many IBS
jokes it ends with like it's never going
to get you you know what I mean when he
made that joke that [__] hurt me a
little bit I was like oh [__] oh [__]
you're just like oh yeah
yikes I hate that he I see like I wish
he didn't say anything at the
end I wish he was just serious the whole
time like you said like if he wasn't
trying to even be a comedian
definitively all of this stuff is highly
effective yeah 100% man and then if you
say all that and at the end you're like
how come none of you guys
left yeah and he's confused too you know
for him he's saying oh there's the you
know comedy where emotional truth is
important and the facts are important
later yes with comedy you're not doing
comedy that's a true statement but it
doesn't apply to exactly it's not
applicable exactly you told this story
about harassment about what the state of
the world is what it's like to be a
brown boy being rejected by anti-muslim
sentiment exactly where is the com like
that's not political that's comedic
storytelling yeah and you know for the
Dave Chappelle thing when he told the
joke when he told the story about his F
friend right there wasn't comedy there
he ended on a very serious note and he
didn't consider that part of the standup
even though he had funny moments in it I
wouldn't call that the best part of his
special he's addressing the controversy
surrounding him exactly that's the note
that he ended on with his special with
the serious tone but the rest of the
series was just so [__] funny oh dude
yeah right so him you know him talking
about like the white guy that broke in
and the shotgun and everything like that
you know what I mean that was comedy
whether it happened if it's real or not
doesn't really [__] matter and if
turned out it wasn't true it doesn't
change anything exactly right right
right it doesn't it doesn't shift
sentiments yeah and I think that's
something that he might have to take
away from in this is like if I took this
out would it change anything if it was
true or not if it doesn't then you're
probably in the clear right and I've
told stories on this podcast where I
have definitely embellished stories
right but 99% of it is true it's just
like the little small clip or you
condense it for time or so you don't
have to say so many details it's like d
i told a story about when I was a kid I
at a bus stop where there was this
African kid that was bullied every
[__] day right there was this dude
named oh let's not say his name but he
bullied the Bethany yeah his name was
Bethany and Bethany bullied this kid
every day and this kid this African kid
one day I told this on JK news and
people didn't believe me uh until these
videos on Twitter started coming up of
these African kids beating other people
up with like their belts and like random
sticks there's this African kid and I
[__] you [__] not this is true as
hell so this dude used to make fun of
this African every day African kid every
day and one day at the bus stop he's
dressed like in this puffy jacket this
the the Old Navy fleece thing a long
shirt another t-shirt and a a wife
beater and he's slowly peeling off all
the [__] right I'm like what the [__] is
happening and then we see him un
unbuckle his belt he takes off his belt
I'm like oh this motherfucker's about to
get naked this guy lost his mind he
unbuckles his belt starts to take off
his pants and inside his pants was a
table leg and he looks at the and he
goes after him and he goes not today M
[__] and he [__] beat the [__] out
of this kid that line has stuck in my
head forever right now the part that I
embellish in the story was when this
fool got hit in his back and his back
arched so hard that the back of his neck
touched his ass you know what I'm saying
yeah no [__] like that's the part that's
a lie the everything else is real the
line not today M [__] really happened
and that could have been the lie you
know what I'm saying he literally said
not
today that's the true part that's the
true part the part that I lied about is
where the back of his neck touched his
ass you know what I'm saying oh my God
and that's a real story that happened so
whether that part is real or true or not
it's still funny and nobody gets hurt
right right you know I'm not making a
thing about you know you would think
that that's the part that you would make
up cuz it's the funniest part I'm not
I'm not smart enough to make that part
up that part's real he literally said
not today and he beat this [__]
with a table leg like straight up at the
bus stop an actual Table leg an actual
Table leg that was in his [__] pants
and he had to take off eight layers
eight layers to get to it I thought this
dude was trying to [__] I'm like yo
what's going on that guy never went to
our school again he had a younger
brother and he moved to another school
too damn I hope he's okay I hopefully
he's a [__] warlord somewhere else
yeah that's like that's like literally
like in Captain Phillips that's like
making up the line I'm the captain now
but the ship really got pirated
he's known in like Africa cuz he went
back he has a tattoo that says [__]
NTM what is what does that mean not
today everybody knows what this means
here I don't care for Dean I I hope he's
out there telling the story and not
leaving that part out I hope not too
they're like what' you say he's like I
didn't say anything no I was there I
heard what you said D my I would never
say that you liar I was a great
Christian boy I never I never raised my
head David is out there spreading
rumors this stupid Asian boy keeps
telling the story about me I don't care
keeps on adding dialogue I did not say
anything I swear [__] I don't
care I didn't say anything then or today
[__] what's that tattoo on your
ey don't worry not today [__] he
just says it all the
time you hungry not today but
F just all the time that's what he says
for everything what a [__] guy dude
oh man I'm so glad that he stood up to
his bullies hell yeah dude it was it my
God I mean they would roast the [__] out
of this kid I felt so bad wait were the
other dudes also they sounded like that
too no the other guys it was a black
dude so it was a black American African
kid they were just [__] with it and
you know back in the day they would make
they would make fun of like dark kids
like skin colors all the time I'm not
talking about white people I'm talking
about Black Folk would make fun of like
African dude skin colors
yeah yeah dog I I I've used this joke
before too where this fo told this guy
look it's not my joke but this is joke
that he said to this kid and I really do
think that this was like the last straw
and I'm not sure I can't remember the
timeline but I was dying laughing and if
you're asking me David why didn't you
stand up for him I would have just got
roasted so I'm just I got roasted every
day for being a fat Asian kid I'm G to
sit the [__] down and be quiet so when
the when the [__] trauma went to
somebody else I just let it happen cuz
it was it was either him or me why shift
the energy man exactly but he said this
[__] to this kid one time and I remember
everybody was dying he
goes it's I can't remember the exact
line right now but it was something
along the lines of he was standing he
goes he goes I can't tell if you're
standing up or lying on the floor cuz
and he pointed at his
shadow then like the whole school
[__] died laughing and the kid didn't
speak much English so he just kind of
can't roast back you know what I'm say
so he just kind of took that [__] and
then just that one time where he was
just got sick of it and the one time I
heard him spoke cuz he never really
talked was not today
[__] and he beat the living [__]
out of him and rightfully so why I
wonder why that day was it a holiday
that he that is so funny he doesn't know
English but that was the only not thing
he knows how to
say what's your name no today fuer I
don't know tell me tomorrow I guess you
coming to work not to D my but he wants
to go to work so bad oh I need to make
money so you're not coming in not today
[__] dude that's see that's the
thing it's like embellishment it it's
not a across theboard deal like yeah
those are three highly different
situations that first one second and
third one completely different yeah but
that's a smart order he put it in to
like win you over with the first that
you're like so drastically apologetic
cuz we are and then on the second one
he's like
hey smart thing of him right and once
again Hass I apologize for that first
part the other two and three I think
it's a little
shaky and look you have a branding issue
right now you know yeah if you're going
to be a comic be a [__] comic right
right do that first make us laugh first
and then think about the other stuff
second but if you're coming out here
saying that my objective is to make you
laugh you are failing super bad yeah I
mean you're embellishing Anthrax
situations like what what is that with
your daughter that's only funny if
you're lying
yeah like if he made a joke it's like
dude my daughter got [__] tricked by
Anthrax because she's fat as [__] she
thought it was powdered sugar like that
is a [__] you know what I'm saying my
fat [__] daughter keeps eating
Anthrax because she keeps thinking it's
powdered Donuts keeps eating at you know
what I'm saying it's habitual yeah
that's like a funny version of this
thing that could have been true you know
oh my God so like the Saudis found out
my daughter's fat so they keep sending
her [__] powdered
Donuts you know what I'm saying that
makes sense they started labeling it
Anthrax she still eats
it maybe that would work you know what
I'm saying oh my god oh well anyway
maybe you should go back to his specials
and just like comedy everything yeah
it's like maybe you should try this a
little bit maybe try this out right but
once again who am I to say anything
right like I'm not I'm not in his realm
he's highly successful like exactly I I
have no right to say this cuz I'm just
saying from a viewer's point and not
from a stand up Comics I don't do
standup anymore but I just from a viewer
point I'm talking from a consumer's
point of view yeah yeah yeah not not
some Hy toyy [__] I have no right to
criticize him about standup because he
is the one who's doing it and he's a way
better standup than I ever was
but that hurt to say that didn't it what
are you talking about I have
IBS oh it kills every time yeah
yeah hate to go after that
joke I would love to go after that joke
hey guys so that was rash
anyways
anys everybody's going to hate me and I
just don't care I don't care for
D well guess what I'll just say not
today [__] but yeah I mean even
not being a St of comedian like it's
easy to tell where the problem comes
from and it's like dude that's the
reason it's because what you're saying
is not considered comedy to everybody
yeah and the part you're lying about not
the punchline or the joke or Aids in it
like if he would have done that and then
ended with like this is where I [__]
up like I do so much political [__] that
I sometimes don't know if I'm being
comedically funny or if I'm trying to do
an emotional pull and so that's my bad
like I got to really work on this comedy
part because I keep thinking that
everything is supposed to be funny but
it's not coming off that way and so I I
get it which he kind of does a little
bit but I don't really know man hey
that's and also too he's really goodlook
so the other part too that kind of makes
me feel weird he's like I'm this guy
that no you're goodl looking I know you
can't play the underdog car dude yeah I
could you know what I'm saying I'm a
little Kim Jong uni here you know what
I'm saying I'm a little sigh looking
you're goodlooking as [__] look at that
facial hair you [__] handsome [__] I
don't want to hear dude he's highly
handsome yeah I don't want to hear a
good-looking guy tell me what it's like
to be not wanted oh do you have you ever
walked into a club looked at a girl and
she threw up huh and I understand if his
and that really happened if his youth
was different and his upbringing was
like disadvantages I get that but it's
like from where you're sitting now it's
hard to and by the way you were in Davis
there's so many Indians there there's so
many Muslim and Indians there dude I'm
sorry like I I grew up in Sacramento so
I know yeah yeah yeah so I don't know
man I don't know what you talking about
anyways guys H once again I apologize
for the first half that's it
um genius BR every Sundays at 12 12 pm.
Ryan plug your [__] ryanr on Instagram
and you can also see me on just kidding
news all the time baby secret society
new launches out make sure you guys
check that out that's r t s o c i e t y
June be matcha everywhere we have stores
opening up all over the place if you
guys want a franchise uh leave it in the
messages below and I'll link you to the
right people because we are taking over
matcha baby let's go well you got to end
it with your best IBS joke okay so a
real Slammer my mom had um Asian hate
and she got beat up and she broke her
eye socket I have
diarrhea his master class is going to be
that every Sunday is at 12: p.m. we'll
see you all next time peace genius brain
listeners thank you for listening to
this episode but before we sign off this
podcast was brought to you by Harry's
Harry's has you covered for the best
shave of your life at a price you'll
love I have used Harry's razors and
products on my face for the longest time
and look at me smooth as a baby's bottom
get better quality at a better price
than other razors when you get haries
delivered right to your door so get your
best shave ever this summer with Harry's
razors and skincare products get a $13
starter set for just $3 at harry's.com
genius that's harry's.com genius for a
$3 starter set